có bạn nghĩ rằng là thì mình sẽ làm là một rồi,
các bạn là 2 trong một đề tức thực gì vậy?
Chúng ta hoàn toàn có thể lý rá mắc thế làm được.
Bây giờ, lým tức tế ra thì với những bạn nào mà là mới,
của bạn, với những bạn nào mới,
như thế là những bạn nào cũng hiểu bạn chắc của các thịt tập,
thì mình đang buồn ở đây, rất nhiều của họ,
bấy bệnh nữa.
Bây giờ các bạn là của họ thì cũng dùng hết.
Bây giờ, tết theo là phần có hoàn,
vì đúng sai, có hoàn cũng sai,
ở đây chúng ta không sẽ có muốn chưa muốn có hoàn.
Bây giờ, cũng đều là có hoàn,
chủ yếu là phải bằng đi phía thôi.
Bây giờ, mình sẽ xấu của mình đi phía có mạc và xí nhiên
còn có hoàn gây tránh cái.
Bây giờ, mình sẽ là đẹn lại không phải là một đề tức.
Nhưng các bạn tượng, là mình sẽ rất là hai,
có thể hai cả tả mà,
xem là, và hai cái chiếc thăm tham cho đề thí làm hai.
Bây giờ, để mình có hoàn rất là hai.
Bây giờ, và và và và và và chiếp,
mình sẽ rất là khi về phần đi phía của các bạn.
Bây giờ, có phía nhất phần tình phóng là nó đau của tụi bần xuống à.
Công là phần trang nhất cho mình ăn.
Bây giờ, con này thì thì như vậy,
con bà của mà của hỏi trung, để xin nhạc.
Bà của hỏi trung.
Công bộ của hai thì nó bây bần cảm tự trung xuống.
Các bạn đang trang,
câu bà của bồn thì nó bây bài bỏa,
vì khi biết được, nó bài bỏa bỏa nó,
khi tốt chuyển động,
nó thấy đồ,
ăn xuất và phía tiếp,
để xà,
câu lắm của sảo thì nó bây bỏa tỏa chết.
Nói chung là câu trúc đề tí,
thì khá là dưới để cho các bạn biết,
thì nó là câu trúc đề tý trận gọi.
Bây xà, nhưng mà thì thì là những năm sau,
các bạn có mất mại được,
cái gia đe này của một độc của một cuộc sách khói,
cái gia đe khán của các mới nữa,
để cho các bạn,
và đây là một cái đe dưới rất là đáng,
để cho các bạn thông khá,
với là các bạn có thay gái chiếm.
Làm này thông ra để tý trộ đồ của đáng của các bạn,
của bạn nhá.
Bây giờ,
thì vào,
hôm nay là tốt này,
thì tức sẽ có một bội,
lại xuy viet,
thì chỉ thông,
và trước trường mà,
nó có hỏi,
nó thay cho một nổi chính thương này.
Bà đau bố nhất,
thay này,